not exactly an anti-bucklist but uh when
did you guys start to realize
I just don't want to do [__] shots
again
I was like shots like a camera
um that is actually when you mature as a
human being yeah that's the peak
maturing point that might have happened
like
I don't know yeah because I I I'm trying
to remember the exact moment when I
thought shots means I'm gonna have a
good night versus shots mean I'm gonna
have a [__] terrible time because
anyone as confused for whatever reason
can't talk about alcoholic shots yeah I
think I think maybe when I was like
definitely early 20s for me was when it
stopped like 23 24 I think when I moved
to Japan yeah 100 Japan I was like yeah
I think I just don't want to do shots
anymore
like there's no occasion and now I
pretty much do everything in my power to
avoid it yeah yeah yeah and even
sometimes if I'm given a shot and
there's like a a can of something else
nearby that's near everything yeah I'll
be like oh thanks guys okay that's why I
don't like drinking with Americans
because so many of them it doesn't
matter how old they are they're just
like let's do [__] tequila shots and
I'm just like no I do not hold on is
that your American impression yeah what
the [__] is that that's a valley girl
impression who are you having drinks
with joy [__] mailing
every time I'm drinking with mainly
she's like Joey I think you should do a
tequila shot I'm just like [__] off
mainly I don't want I don't even like
tequila no one likes to kill her except
Americans do Americans do yeah yeah it's
weird because I remember did you did you
ever you know in in Australia did you
have ring of fire at all was that it was
that a good call or something else we
call it something else though right [__]
what do we call it I know what you're
talking about though yeah so Ring of
Fire is I think like a staple of like
every at least British uni where you
have like a pint in the middle which is
called the Dirty pints uh and then you
have a bunch of cards around that point
uh and you pick up a different card and
different cards
at once I don't think we are not at
least not like Ring of Fire
um because I remember like the what like
the the one experience that I was like
I'm never playing ring of fire again was
uh we for some reason we this was like
[__] uh at midnight so we already had
a few drinks and uh we thought oh
[__] dirty Point that's too boring
you know alcohol that's too boring let's
spice things up and uh We've started
putting some [__] uh like [__] like
hot sauce and like washing up Liquid in
there washing up like washing up
yeah this was [__] somebody drink
washing up Liquid yeah I did I lost
um how are you alive sorry yeah yeah
that like kill you that's like bleach uh
yeah I I was I was a [__] dumbass kid
yeah this I was a [__] dumbass kid I
was 18 years old generally you threw it
up instantly yeah I did throw it up
instantly why would you risk your life
with that this is this is this is why
people when they're like man I don't
drink camera too yeah yes please do it
for the cloud you know
yeah and I I just think about some of
the [__] stupid [__] I did back in
the day and uh and now yeah hopefully
hopefully we're more mature right
hopefully I haven't well I haven't seen
you drink washing up Liquid so I feel
like you're more mature slightly no yeah
luckily I survived that to uh never do
that again what's the dumbest thing
you've done during like a drinking
session yours is washing up yeah we used
to do that too we used to have a rule
where you could put anything in the in
the cabinets in it oh [__] so people
would put stuff like
um cooking oil oh you could ingest but
you couldn't keep it down that's like a
tear down
she's the average American diet nearly
Beast drank like three liters of that
[__] and yeah yeah exactly exactly
by the way when I say washing up Liquid
it was it was unlike a few drops
it was normal right but I don't want
people to think they just want friends
that's putting like a tide pot on the
corner of the glass and being like wow
look at the garnish I think the dumbest
thing I did was um like it involves
tequila another reason why I hate to
kill but like you know a normal to kill
a shot for those of you who don't know
because you'd pour the salt you know on
your hand where it was somewhere on your
hand right and then you you'd have a
lemon in the other hand and you you'd
lick the salt you do the shot and then
you eat the lemon right that's that's
the standard tequila shot uh we did this
thing called uh what is called a
kamikaze shot which is essentially the
same thing it's the salt and the lemon
and the tequila shot but what you do is
you snort the salt you take this shot
and then you pour the lemon in your eye
that's the point of that uh just seeing
someone else do it that's not you is
[__] hilarious
it's also very dangerous but it's really
funny when you're not the one doing it
why does every drinking thing just sound
so [__] stupid because it is and if
you count if you're counting chewies uh
as being stupid then I've done plenty of
those yeah never again
chewy is just unhygienic it's not like
yeah it's just gross yeah it's just
gross because like you know you like
every time I talk to someone from
Australia or England or Europe everyone
has like everyone has that one drink
right it's it's the first drink you
learned that uh you drunk too much of
and then you threw up and then you can
it's like a core memory now you know
what I mean it's like every time you
smell that drink you're like no I can't
do it that's wrong for me is that wrong
yeah oh which sucks because it's like I
actually like a lot of rum drinks but
the moment I smell any kind of ram I'm
just like I'm reminded of those
traumatic experiences can't drink them
for me it's a for me it's something I
remember uh I remember this was uh I
think about a New Year's Eve party with
my cousins this book is so gross yeah I
mean it is it is gross so nice and I
remember at the time I thought it was uh
like pretty nice tasting because I was
like oh it's like a sweet shot it's not
nothing like nothing like a vodka shot
or a whiskey shot it's actually got a
bit of flavor to it uh I guess yeah I
mean that's that's all right
kid gone was huffing copia yeah yeah he
was he was I mean let's let's say it was
a step up from washing up Liquid okay
I think anything
oh
it's clear that's how it works I think
it works okay I'm getting this cool
memory back because I think I think it
uh traumatized me over two things okay
because apparently what I did I didn't I
didn't actually throw up because I tried
because my my all of our parents were in
like the other room and it was just like
us cousins like getting like shit-faced
drunk yeah uh so I tried my best to
basically like sober up right so what I
did was there was no food in the
cupboard except for a few loaves of
Hovis bread
I just sat there for about three hours
just like nibbling on this bread finish
one loaf [__] God I started another
loaf of bread
I went through two loaves of bread the
entire impressive amount of bread
together and then it was only after I
finished the second where I was like I
can't hold anything anymore is this why
you don't like breath I'm thinking maybe
I was like [__] I completely forgot this
happened but maybe this experience just
traumatized me on every single types of
bread as well just washing up like it
you can get multi-organ failure
following a large ingestion well uh wow
but it would cause you nausea and
vomiting yeah which you most certainly
would vomit yeah yeah God damn why what
is with what is with kids I'm not being
dumb yeah
um that's why I like you know I grew out
of that phase very quickly I think
because I mean the moment you're like
throwing up and having horrible time I
think is when you you kind of realize
like is this fun this is not fun I don't
think fitting in is fun yeah yeah have
you guys ever been like blackout drunk
oh yeah of course I've had like that's
only happened to me once and that like
terrified me enough to like never want
to like do it again yeah I mean it's all
it's all a learning experience that's
again that's another reason why I don't
drink tequila anymore alcohol is uh is
in in moderation can be great and a fun
time yeah and you know I think again
anyone who any anytime I meet someone
like I don't drink I'm like you're so
smart yeah yeah actually respect yeah uh
even more respect to people who have
decided to stop drinking yeah yeah I
know a few of as well yeah yeah I think
it's it's good I'm definitely drinking
less uh as I'm getting older that's for
sure like so I feel like eventually I'm
gonna get to that point where I'm just
like you know what I think I'm good yeah
I think it's smart
um yeah I mean obviously if you drink
especially if you're raised in the kind
of like the British Australian culture
you'll have gone you know well you're
kind of encouraged to get smashed yeah
yeah especially in University